[Music]
should you preemptively kill a zombie of
course I believe it was either cleaning
the elder or Ving Rhames who said it is
good to kill zombies but on this matter
I suspect the founders would consult
John Locke stipulated there are many
kinds of zombies fast slow undead rage
virus Chicago voters but in every case
the societal collapse of a zombie
apocalypse qualifies as what John Locke
called a state of war a state of
permanent conflict of all against all
like in The Walking Dead or a Black
Friday sale at Target all the zombies
want to eat your face or brains for
Locke this is a settled design upon
another man's life Locke continues one
may destroy a man who makes war upon him
for the same reason he may kill a wolf
or lion because such men are not under
the ties of the common law of reason and
will be sure to destroy him whenever he
falls into their power will humans need
killing in that context surely there's
no need to debate the undead how will
you prepare for the zombie apocalypse
let us know in your comments also let us
know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI